getting to egypt by the way was the most
hassle i've ever had on a reporting trip
it was the fact that when i arrived in
egypt absolutely no one wanted to talk
to me by going to the suez canal i
visited the suez canal control tower and
seeing for myself how things worked it
was only by going to the litigation in
in the court in ismailia and hearing the
lawyers talk about the problems on the
bridge that we learned all this new
information
the giant container ship is blocking the
suez canal one of the world's busiest
waterways the route is vital for the
movement of everything from oil to
consumer goods initially people blamed
strong winds but you know it was never a
very satisfactory explanation simply
because strong winds in that part of the
world happen for about half the year bad
weather may not be the main reason why
the ship got stuck
it could have been a technical or a
human ever that will be revealed through
the investigation according to evidence
that was presented in an egyptian court
the pilots at one point were arguing
shouting at each other trading insults
so if this lasts for you know anything
more than a day um it could cause major
headaches for global shipping and energy
markets why did the situation even occur
in the first place this ship is so huge
it's as long as the empire state
building is tall and it is blocking the
entire width of the sewers canal since
it ran aground on tuesday i think most
of us aren't aware
of just how much global trade hangs by a
thread
hi my name's kit and i'm a reporter for
bloomberg i thought it was critical to
to actually go to egypt to report this
story i visited the sewers canal
authority i spoke to the chief pilots
i attended a couple of the court
hearings
and saw the ship owners lawyers make the
argument for the first time that there
had been some fault in the hands of the
suez canal pilots
i'm matthew campbell i'm a reporter and
editor for bloomberg businessweek
so modern ships of all sizes really have
something called a voyage data recorder
on the bridge the idea is to capture
audio of everything that goes on so in
the case of the ever given
as in so many marine accidents
this evidence from the vdr became really
critical to determining what actually
occurred the urgent effort to dislodge a
cargo ship stuck in the suez canal
blocking a key global trading route this
is a traffic jam like no other there was
this rippling cascade of disruption to
global trade and therefore lots and lots
of people who might argue that they lost
money as a result of what occurred on
board the ever given in late march
then the happenings on the bridge what
was recorded by the vdr
becomes a matter of incredible
sensitivity because it is just crucial
evidence
[Music]
ships have
with some exceptions just gotten bigger
and bigger over the last 30 or 40 years
the ever given if you include the value
of the ship the value of the fuel on
board and the 17 000 odd containers it
was carrying it comes to about a billion
dollars
this is one of the largest objects that
humans have ever put on the ocean there
was a crew of 25
led by a captain named krishnan
kanthavel a very experienced mariner
from tamil nadu
it had set sail from asia and was due to
arrive in rotterdam a couple of weeks
later
in the suez canal you typically transit
early in the morning
so the ever given would have been
emerging
from the red sea coming into the suez
canal
there were
terrible winds at that point a whipping
sand a really severe storm and enough
wind in fact that some vessels decided
that they did not want to proceed
through the canal
on that day
the captain of the ever given captain
canthavel would have had a choice about
whether to proceed it is always the
final decision of the captain but there
are huge financial pressures on a
captain in this situation the shipping
industry is a just-in-time business a
captain of his experience would be
keenly aware that there were huge
amounts of money riding on getting his
cargo to europe on time
[Music]
if you look at the sewers canal from our
satellites it looks like a fairly
straight shot through the desert with a
couple of lakes on the way
you would imagine i imagined that it
wouldn't be particularly difficult to
steer a ship straight through the
passage but actually it's a very
stressful thing to do uh we're told by
all the all the sailors and captains
that we spoke to it's a very narrow gap
in places 200 meters or so wide and
quite shallow so any mistake you know is
liable to cause an incident of some kind
so when big ships come into narrow
waterways typically they will take on
board at least one pilot then a pilot is
someone who really intimately knows a
particular area and can advise the
captain and the helmsman of a ship who
who may not be familiar with that
waterway on what to avoid
dangerous currents submerged hazards
that kind of thing they don't actually
steer the ship but they give
instructions as to the best way to get
through and they have to communicate
with the captain and the other crew on
the bridge of the ever given which is a
difficult conversation to have because
the captain and the crew are mostly
using english
the egyptian pilots would mostly have
been speaking in arabic so it would have
been quite difficult for them to have a
have a proper conversation
we were told by almost everyone we
interviewed that the dynamic between the
captain and the crew and the local
egyptian officials
can be a tense one when they're going
through sewers and there's a few reasons
for that the captain is the master of
his ship in normal circumstances he has
complete control over the crew
he's the boss but when you go through
suez you know you have to surrender some
of that control to the local pilots
whose job it is to steer the vessel
through the canal
when you do speak to people in the
shipping industry
you will quickly learn that suez pilots
have a pretty mixed reputation we had
lots of reports of pilots asking for
cigarettes for example asking for other
gifts in return for their cooperation in
getting through the canal and all these
things add up to make it quite a fraught
situation
[Music]
so the ever given comes into the canal
in these very windy conditions and you
have to think about the scale here this
is a vessel that is 400 meters long it's
also at the top of its containers more
than 50 meters above the water line
so it really is an enormous surface for
the wind to smack against
and what appears to have happened is
the ever given began to act as a sort of
sail and was swerving back and forth in
the canal and we know from some of the
evidence that's come out in in legal
proceedings that there was an argument
on the bridge between the two egyptian
pilots they were arguing about speed the
weather and we know that when the
captain tried to get in the middle of
the argument and calm things down one of
the egyptian pilots threatened to just
leave the ship leave his post
at some point as the vessel was swerving
back and forth one of the pilots
according to what we know from the
voyage data recorder
gave the order to go full ahead and that
would have taken the ever given speed to
about 13 knots and
speeding up is supposed to give you more
control it gives you more purchase on
the rudder when you're trying to steer
one of these enormous ships
and in the normal circumstances that
would be a good way to regain control
but
the situation at that moment it was the
worst thing they could have done because
the ship is in such a narrow channel
that increasing the speed actually
conversely can make it much harder to
control because of something called
bernoulli's principle and the basic idea
is that as water rushes faster or any
fluid rushes faster the pressure
decreases and because there's less
pressure the vessel is sucked toward one
bank or the other
that then became a problem as the
captain and the helm and the bridge crew
fought to keep control of the vessel
there were according to what we know
from the voyage data recorder orders
given in rapid succession from the
pilots to go hard to port or hard to
starboard so eventually one of these
turns went past the point where it could
be recovered and the bow of the ever
given lodged right into the sand
the ship just slows down and then
suddenly you realize you've crashed
so the ever given was stuck in one of
the southern reaches of the canal quite
close to the southern entrance
now the suez has been expanded over the
years most recently in 2015 critically
those expansions have been aimed at at
allowing two-way traffic for the most
part because originally the canal was
was only wide enough for vessels to go
in one direction at once however
where the ever given was stuck was a
one-way section there was no bypass
around it
somehow when they crashed they managed
to not only wedge the front into the
desert
but the back of the ship also grounded
as well so the ship was left diagonally
wedged completely blocking the channel
by the end of the first day there would
have been 100 or so
vessels anchored waiting to transit and
that number grew steadily hour by hour
every day
goods worth 10 billion dollars were
arriving at the canal waiting to go
through
look around you in any room you happen
to be in right now
the vast majority of the objects in that
room will have come to you on boats
and if you live in western europe if you
live in north america it is very likely
that those boats pass through the suez
canal so every company that deals with
physical stuff
depends on this waterway in one fashion
or another so having it blocked is just
a titanically important problem
and one that that there were billions of
dollars riding on resolving quickly the
400 meter long cargo ship the ever given
is stuck in the suez canal and it is
fouling up global trade 50 ships a day
normally pass through the canal carrying
12 percent of the world's trade so the
pressure is really on to get her
re-floated
the ship crashed at such speed that the
front uh went six or seven meters
directly into quite rocky sand
two tugboats arrived very quickly
um they were just routine tugboats they
weren't especially large or powerful but
they immediately made efforts to pull
the ship free and it didn't move an inch
it was clear it was firmly stuck
the main entity with responsibility for
for clearing the canal and freeing the
ship is the suez canal authority which
is the egyptian government entity that
controls the canal
and the man in charge
of the pilots at least is the chief
pilot captain el-sayed he was one of the
first on the scene and he with his boss
chairman robbie put together a plan to
try and get the ship free
initially they realized that that simply
pulling probably wasn't going to be
enough they would have to dig as well
the front of the ship was wedged so deep
in the bank that they would need to do
some digging one of the earliest photos
we have is of a small
yellow excavator
right up against the front of the ship
just scooping out scoop after scoop of
sand
and you know it looks ridiculous next to
the size of the vessel it looks hopeless
this uh
somewhat anonymous uh egyptian guy
became a global internet celebrity when
photos of this went viral uh just a kind
of metaphor for being stuck in a
hopeless task
the vessel's owners quite quickly hired
a dutch firm called smit
who are one of the most prominent
salvage firms in the world so a team of
experts from smit flew in from the
netherlands and elsewhere
and see if there was a way that they
could help get this ship off
salvage teams are awarded a percentage
of whatever they say generally there are
different ways to pay them but that's
the traditional fashion
now if you're a salvage crew and you
save a big fully loaded oil tanker for
example from sinking
you could be in line for tens of
millions of dollars
so the team from smith arrived on the
morning of march 25th so that's about
two days
after the ground the view of these
salvage experts from smith
was that preparations needed to be made
immediately
to begin bringing containers off hiring
a crane coming up with a plan to offload
these big very heavy boxes
in order to lighten the vessel now
there were some people at the suez canal
authority as our understanding who
were
more reluctant to consider that option i
think they worked out it was going to
take months to completely offload the
containers from the ever given so they
were facing a much longer delay and a
much longer blockage if they had to try
and take the containers off so the
compromise that was arrived at was
towing would proceed until the time that
a crane arrived and then if at that
point the vessel was still stuck they
would begin unloading it in a situation
where every day the canal is closed
costs the world economy billions of
dollars no one felt they had time to
wait
[Music]
on the 28th of march that was a sunday
you had two
very powerful tugs turn up from the
south combined had something like 200 or
300 tons of pulling power
the tide is of course very important
you want more water that means more
buoyancy more ability to lift the ship
clear of whatever it's stuck on
there was actually at the end of march a
super moon a time when the moon is
unusually close to earth tidal peaks are
higher so if you happen to be trying to
get a 400 meter container ship
off a sandy bank that's potentially
quite important because you have more
water to work with so everyone knew that
march 28th to march 29th was the best
opportunity for weeks that the salvers
were going to have to pull the ever
given clear there was no sudden movement
or noise they just suddenly realized
their tugs instead of treading water
were moving and they were moving because
the back had very slowly started to move
away from the bank so the rear the rear
was freed first but the front was still
wedged
one of the worries was that when the bow
did finally come free it would swing
clear across the canal
first of all potentially
doing terrible damage to anyone who was
in the way which included lots of
vessels from the suez canal authority
and potentially also swinging right into
the opposite bank grounding itself again
so during the towing operations
the crew of the ever given had helped
set up
cables from the bow of their vessel to
shore four in total so that when the bow
did finally come clear it could be held
from swinging right across the canal
smith came up with an idea to take on
ballast water into the ballast tanks at
the rear of the ever given
the back is
pushed down and the front is lifted ever
so slightly that slight lift at the
front
turned out to be just enough
to help them lift out of the sand
so when the tide change and the waters
were flowing out and the two powerful
tugs were pulling in the same direction
that was when the front finally came
clear and when that happened everything
happened quite quickly
there was jubilation
as you can imagine
they all sounded their horns at the same
time could be heard from miles away one
of the egyptian dredgers was cheering
and shouting number one number one
so once the ever given was free it was
towed up to the great bitter lake which
is a body of water part way up the canal
and it sat there during what became a
pretty tense legal standoff
you had the suez canal authority
which is part of the egyptian government
demanding compensation of more than 900
million dollars
in exchange for letting the vessel go
now the egyptians claimed that part of
this was a so-called salvage award which
is the percentage of value that you're
entitled to when you rescue a vessel
part was also for what amounted to
reputational damages the owners of the
ever given and frankly a lot of people
observing this around the world
thought that figure was absurd the
egyptian government reduced their ask to
550 million i think it's probably a safe
bet that the settlement came in
somewhat below that
but we just don't know in any case it is
a great deal of money
[Music]
one of the amazing things about shipping
is that it's kind of invisible to most
of us the ships have become too big for
ports in manhattan or in east london so
the ports have moved elsewhere
so actually shipping has kind of receded
from view
but in that time
it has become
an even more important part of our lives
than ever before everything we depend on
all the material goods all the energy
all the oil we put in our cars
everything we shop for at a place like
ikea or walmart it all comes on ships
for about a week the whole world was
riveted by shipping and also understood
in some ways how fragile it is
and all it took was a one wrong turn
effectively for that to all be shut down
you